solve the equation 40 and express your
answer in terms of base 10 logarithms
and this equation says 10 10 to the 2t
minus 3 is equal to 7 we want to solve
for T in terms of base 10 logarithms so
let me get my little scratch pad out and
I've copied and pasted the same problem
so I'm just going to rewrite it so they
have 10 to the 2t minus 3 is equal to 7
actually let me color code this a little
bit so 10 to the 2t 2 t minus 3 is equal
to 7 so this is clearly an exponential
form right over here if we want to write
it in logarithmic form weird that will
essentially allow us to solve for the
exponent so we could say this is the
exact same truth about the universe as
saying that the log log base 10 log base
10 of 7 is equal to is equal to 2t minus
3 2 t minus 3 let's just make sure that
makes sense this is saying 10 to the 2 3
minus 3 is equal to 7 this is saying
that the power that I need to raise 10
to to get to 7 is 2t minus 3 or 10 to
the 2t minus 3 power is equal to 7 so
these are equivalent statements what
this form does is it starts to put into
a form that's easier to solve for T now
if we want to solve for T we can add 3
to both sides so if we add 3 to both
sides add 3 to both sides we are going
to get log base 10 of 7 of 7 plus 3 plus
plus 3 and this plus 3 is of course
outside of the logarithm to make it
clear it's like well it's just like that
and on the right hand side this is going
to be equal to this is going to be equal
to just 2t and now to solve for T we
just divide both sides by 2 so if we
divide both sides by 2 we get T is equal
to all of this business log base Avot
log log base 10 of 7 plus
3 all of that over 2 so let me see if I
can if I can remember this and write it
in my little light and write and write
it in the actual box that they gave us
so we want to do log base 10 of 7 and
then that plus 3 yep it's formatting it
right / - so that's what I'm claiming
that T is equal to in terms of base 10
logarithms so let me check my answer and
I got it right